899 and Alfred the Great of Wessex is
dead throughout his life he built up the
kingdom of Wessex from this to this
managing to turn Mercier into what was
essentially a puppet state alfred was
succeeded by his son Edward better known
as Edward the elder but if you want to
be very angry Saxon about it which you
do his name was they add weird Etha Walt
who was the son of Alfred's brother and
predecessor Ethelred revolted against
Edward claiming the throne for himself
fortunately for Edward Ethel Ward's
revolt did not come to much
to summarize Ethel Walt fled Wessex and
managed to gain the support of the Danes
in East Anglia in attacking Wessex but
he was killed at the Battle of the home
which was probably about here
boring Ethel wall very little is known
about the early reign of King Edward an
information of him doesn't become clear
until 9/11 when Ethel read The Lord of
Mercy had died Edward then seized these
mercy England's which notably included
London shortly afterwards he marched
into East Anglia and seized all of these
lands with the help of the local angles
after this ethelred's Widow and Edward
sister Ethel Fred ruled over Mercier and
together with Edward began to put
pressure on the neighbouring Danelaw
over most of the next decade
Ethel fled built fortified birds across
Murcia many of which were designed to
protect against race from the Norse
Vikings based in Dublin and on the Isle
of Man Edward also oversaw the
construction of burrs such as the one at
Buckingham and one at Mountain in his
newly conquered territories the most
importantly if anglo-saxon expansion was
9:17 up north Ethel Fred conquered all
of this territory including Derby in its
surrounding territories shortly
afterwards Edward conquered all of East
Anglia and captured the city of grant a
bridge or Cambridge as is now known the
only remnants of the Danelaw were the
Kingdom of York in the remaining four of
the five boroughs
Lester was the next borough to full when
Ethel fled secured a surrender in
nineteen without a fight at this time
the Vikings of York made the offer of
analysed worth or fled to defend against
north Raiders but she died before
anything could come of it
Ethel Fred's daughter elf Winn was
supposed to take over as lady of Murcia
but she was booted out presumably by
merchants who wanted to retain their
independence this didn't happen and
Edward annexed all of Mercier in the
same year soon after this Edward
ventured into the Danelaw again and at
9:18 he took these territories and by
the end of 920 he'd secured the
remaining Danish strongholds and
expanded his kingdom to all of the land
south of the Humber those on the
periphery of this newly enlarged
anglo-saxon kingdom found themselves
having to choose between resisting or
submitting in nine twenty or twenty
depending on which version you read the
anglo-saxon Chronicle claims that the
king of the Scots and all the people of
the Scots and Ragnar to know who lived
in Northumbria both English and Danish
Norseman or other and also the king of
the Strathclyde Welsh and all the
Strathclyde Welsh chose him as father
and Lord soaked by the end of Edwards
reign the kingdom of Wessex looked like
this with roughly these areas pledging
allegiance to Edward Edward himself died
in 924 and was succeeded by his son
Athelstan whose best-known achievement
occurred only three years into his reign
when he captured the City of York and
annexed all of Northumbria including the
non Danish part for many this is
considered the birth of England's as the
last remaining Kingdom with a large
population of anglo-saxons had been
annexed in the same years his conquest
of Northumbria Athelstan received the
submission of the King of Scotland and
the king of Strathclyde much like Edward
had the reason for this was that
submission was to a specific king and
not to the kingdom itself which meant
that these submissions needed to be
renewed the peace between etho stan and
the neighboring kingdoms did not last
forever and in 9:34 it is known that
ethel stan invaded Scotland whether this
was in retaliation for something or just
an attempt to extend his kingdom is not
known though none of the neighboring
kingdoms could resist on their own and
so Scotland Strathclyde in the Kingdom
of Dublin formed an alliance and they
met her those down at the Battle of
brunnen / brew number was extremely
bloody and importantly a victory for
Ethel stand which cemented his position
as the power in the British Isles it is
considered by some to be one of the most
important battles in anglo-saxon history
Athelstan was not merely a conqueror
though and his reign saw a change in the
nature of anglo-saxon government
anglo-saxon society was one dominated by
the aristocracy and one with many social
ranks there were many nuances but the
nobility consisted primarily of two
major ranks the first was the elder man
who was generally in charge of a
province called a Shire but some held
him and held several the other major
rank of nobility was that of the Thane
who held smaller groups of lands both
noble ranks had obligations to the king
such as providing troops dispensing
justice building and maintaining bridges
as well as providing the church in
return for fulfilling these duties
Nobles would expect rewards such as
lands and privileges the bulk of society
consisted of lay people at the main
group being the free peasants called
chose etho Stan's reign was also a
period which saw an increase in
anglo-saxon involvement in continental
affairs for example when the West
Frankish king charles the simple was
deposed and in prison his son Louis was
given refuge Athelstan then helped the
exiled Louis returned to West Frankie to
take the throne and helped to key
in there another Excel Prince could hack
on was helped by Athelstan to take the
throne of Norway from his older brother
Eric thus Eric was exiled and fled to
the British house and would eventually
become a problem
Athelstan wouldn't live to see this
though since he died in 939 he was
succeeded by his half-brother edmund who
had to deal almost immediately with the
Norse invasion led by a man called Olaf
go through sim Olaf seized York and
invaded the Midlands forcing Edmond to
recognize him as the king of Northumbria
and the sovereign of the Eastlands Olaf
continued the long trend of Viking
mortality and died in 941 and was
succeeded by his cousin also called Olaf
soon after Edmond began a reconquest of
his lost territories in 942 here each of
the Midlands and in 944 he drove Olaf
out of Northumbria having reunited the
kingdom of the anglo-saxons Edmond
invaded the neighboring kingdom of
Strathclyde in 945 and basically set
everything on fire he took some of its
southern lands but agreed to give
overlordship of Strathclyde to king
malcolm the first of scotland as a
result of the conquest of the Danelaw
Edmund became known as the Liberator of
the Danes is apparently he'd rescued
them from the harsh rule of the Norse
but the exact details of nossor RI and
reign ended abruptly in 946 when he was
either murdered by a thief or
assassinated no one knows for sure
Edmund was succeeded by his younger
brother a adrift and shortly after this
in 947 the previously exiled erik from
norway better known as heir at blood
acts conquered Northumbria a a turret
erik in the previously driven our olaf
struggle for Northumbria over the next
seven years but in the end a hydra
decisively defeated erik and reclaimed
all of Northumbria after this
Northumbria would permanently remain a
constituent part of the anglo-saxon
kingdom and later england not much else
is known about yet or its reign which
came to an end upon his death in 95
patrick was succeeded by his nephew the
fifteen-year-old a a tree who
immediately had a falling-out with a
prominent abbot who Dunstan who
subsequently fled to Flanders ad Wiis
reign was one played with the issues of
loyalty not much is known about the
exact Quarles but a faction against King
ad we was formed which favored his
brother Edgar for the throne in 9:57 the
elder men of East Anglia Mercia and
Northumbria declared for Edgar civil war
was avoided when it was agreed by the
nobility that the kingdom would be split
a ad we would retain Wessex whereas
Edgar would get the rest which seemed
fair this division wouldn't last long
since they ad we died two years later at
the ripe old age of 19 and Edgar took
over the entire kingdom so Edgar is
mostly known for the numerous reforms he
undertook both political and
ecclesiastical
good was not a conqueror like Alfred
Edward or Ethel Stan but he had the
difficult task of keeping the
newly-formed
anglo-saxon kingdom together and
strengthening the Kings hold over them
much of this was done via legal codes
and charters and interestingly Edgar
allowed the laws previously established
in the Danelaw to remain in force the
reason for this was that forcing
anglo-saxon laws onto an Anglo Danish
population could have caused resentment
and potentially rebellion governing the
realm was undertaken by the Vitara amok
which was a large Royal Council of
nobles and churchmen which met regularly
and decided on important matters of
state such as the succession of kings in
the passing of laws this council
traveled all around the kingdom instead
of staying at the capital of Winchester
under Edgar the status of aldermen
increased but they still had important
administrative positions Ottoman were
appointed by the king and they held a
shire for life the position wasn't
hereditary though and upon the death of
an alderman the land went back to the
king to redistribute as he saw fit the
Shire was the backbone of the
administrative system and the system
implemented by Edgar lasted until its
abolition in 1974 the Shire was divided
into hundreds of weapon takes if in the
old areas of the Danelaw
which had their own cause which met
monthly and was the unit of land used to
assess the raising of troops shockingly
the hundred was made up of 100 hides of
land with the exception of Wessex where
it varied the hundred was divided into
the tithing which was made up of ten
hides in the households that lift upon
them Edgar's reforms were also economic
and he oversaw the standardization of
the kingdom's coinage in 973 it was
ordered that the coins were to be
replaced every six years in order to
reduce counterfeiting and that the coins
had to bear the place it was minted and
the money are in charge of the mint on
the back of their coins probably the
most famous reform from Edgar's reign
was his monastic reformed almost
immediately after he became king he
recorded the abbot Dunstan who became
the Bishop of Worcester before becoming
the Archbishop of Canterbury Dunstan
along with Ethel Ward the Bishop of
Winchester and Oswald the Archbishop of
York oversaw the reform at the
monasteries to simplify it was believed
that the holy houses were not
sufficiently pious anymore partly due to
laziness and partly due to the fact that
Vikings kept burning them down during
his exile Dunstan came into contact with
the european-wide Benedictine reform
movement which sought to restore the
highly structured lifestyles of monks
Etica provided a great deal of lanta
money towards this reform although some
of it was seized from his nobles land
grants and donations were used to found
new monasteries whose residents adhere
to the reformed rules which were
codified in a document with the
regularise concordia whilst Edgar's
reforms are important Edgar's biggest
achievement was keeping the anglo-saxon
kingdoms
after Edgar the unity of the kingdom was
very secure the nobility was more secure
in their position there had been decades
of peace and the kingdom's finances were
much more stable
Edgar wasn't coronated King until the
year 973 when he was 30 years old and 16
years into his reign
shortly after this the other Kings
within Britain came to Chester to
personally pledge their allegiance to
him Edgar would only remain King for
another two years when he died leaving
behind two young sons Edward and
Ethelred who both had their backers
Edward one out in a 90-70 eight three
years into his reign he was invited to
see his brother and stepmother elfreth's
in cafe where he was swiftly murdered
upon his arrival after which he was
remembered as Edward the martyr his
brother succeeded him as king ethelred
ii but he is better known as Ethelred
the unready whose unfortunate rule and
legacy will be examined next week I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching there are some book
recommendations in the description below
if you'd like to know more
you